[Music]
Syrians are turning to the internet for
help
we spoke to Google about what they were
searching for search volumes from the
past two weeks reveal that people are
looking for the closest hospitals how to
treat burns at home and how to perform
mouth-to-mouth resuscitation it's no
wonder that Syrians are trying to get
out and the most popular search terms
are all related to finding a way to
Europe more specifically how to reach
Germany the top two searches coming out
of Syria are immigration to Germany and
asylum in Germany people are also trying
to figure out how to get there
firstly by sea with Greece map and sea
separating Turkey and Greece as the next
top search terms
Syrians also want to see maps of Europe
and Arabic and a map of Germany
naturally they're trying to determine
which is the best route to take by
searching the distance between Edina and
Izmir between Izmir and Istanbul then
Turkey and Greece and once on foot they
want to know the distance between
Macedonia and Serbia as Hungary declares
a state of emergency and uses force to
prevent people from entering its borders
searches reveal that high volumes of
Syrians are looking for news of Hungary
and Hungary Syrian refugees while the
war in Syria continues to take a toll on
those left behind the web seems to be
providing some answers in a time of need
and uncertainty
[Music]
you